ok now this idea this idea of
understanding velocity in terms of
displacement paves the way for even more
important ideas when we come back to
simple harmonic motion in particular ok
so I don't know where you've written
your review if you were writing your
review ok want you to UM write another
subheading which is another differential
equation for simple harmonic motion ok
now i'm going to introduce it the way i
introduced before which is to show you
how this works in the general situation
and then bring it back to simple
harmonic motion ok so here's what we're
going to do you've got here right um
velocity in terms of displacement I want
to get acceleration in terms of velocity
acceleration in terms of velocity how do
I do that well I want you to remember
what is acceleration right as a
derivative as a derivative it's the
first derivative of this function is
that right does that make sense it's the
second derivative of displacement but
it's the first derivative of velocity ok
so i can write it in these terms now
you'll see this in all the textbooks i
find it slightly maddening I'll tell you
what we've shown you right I've shown
you that you can have things in terms X
in dots right x double dot right and an
alternative way to explain that or to
write it is to call this V for velocity
in this a for acceleration or Apple
depending on your mood but this this
mixes up for to which I find very
frustrating it's like we're just just
use one scheme or the other I know why
they do it it's because writing DX dot
is just as confusing frankly so that's
why you're going to see this a whole lot
though try not to get confused ok so all
we've got is
give you a dt here right I'm going to
use the same trick that I did here but
kind of in Reverse ok I want to think
about this in terms of chain rule how do
I get this in terms of X right because
that's that's what this idea here was
right well think about this DB on dt is
kind of like oats it's what happens
after you've done chain rule ok you had
two derivatives are fun and the chain
rule is cancelled and then out came one
nice tribute ok what would be the
preceding line if you were trying to get
to this derivative from chain rule you'd
have DV on something times something on
duty right this would be the chain rule
I that would lead you here ok now when
you write it like this you start to
realize there are that many other
choices are therefore what you could put
in here right you certainly can't put
acceleration because that's over here
right instead you're only other
alternative is this place movie right ok
so how did I get this loan go ahead from
here here I was trying to think about
reversing chain rule that's how I
arrived at this okay um the reason why
I'm Lavery this point is because like I
said text books they will show you this
series of steps and it's cover why why
do any of the steps k to each other
what's the point what are we getting out
ok I'm trying to end up another
different equation a simple home
automation ok and this is the part that
I'm gonna go now have a look at this
this is this is X double dot right by
introducing chain rule in here right
I've like this over here DX on your team
but I know what DX only two years right
that's just velocity isn't it first
derivative with respect to time ok so
this is actually this
I've read room over there okay so look
at him for a second what is this mean at
this point this acceleration in terms of
velocity and how velocity is changing
with this place with respect to
displacement that's a bit confusing but
ok so I'm going to go one step further I
want to get this just in terms of
velocity ok so this D this V here ok I'm
going to do another step of chain rule
but it's going to be a bit confusing all
right I want to get rid of this DV here
Sabine hmm how would I do it I can do
training on this car no I needed on DV
somewhere right times DV on yes now do
it wait oh ok because these db's will
cancel how do I put it in there hmm now
I have a couple of choices right I could
I could introduce another variable like
like times and like that here but
actually there's just going to take me
back where I came from ok so that's
actually not such a good idea instead
what I've got here is well this piece
just comes from here right so what I'm
going to have here should come from this
so what's this going to be if I have for
instance the derivative with respect to
V of something that gives me v figure
out going in the other direction is
there something we can differentiate
with respect to V they're all land us
back on me and the question we're asking
is what's the primitive of V that's what
the primitive is right something that if
you differentiate it with Victor you'll
get this back and the answer is it's
half e squared that's the young well
that's one of the primitives isn't it ok
because if you differentiate this the
two comes out the front power reduces
and there you are you get me ok all
right look at this now I can undo my
channel thing right watch my um my beast
cancel right well my TV's rather
ok so if that cancels with that what do
you get left with is this
hmm have a look at this so this is a bit
confusing okay what does this mean
what's his name this is about
acceleration in terms of velocity
acceleration toes velocity hot a second
this is everything in terms of time so
that means if you can tell me what time
you are right then I can tell you where
you are how fast you're going and what
forces acting on you this one here is
von bossa t sorry acceleration in terms
of displacements so if you can tell me
where you are I can tell you what forces
acting on you so what does this mean
this is acceleration in terms of varsity
this means if you can tell me how fast
you're going in which direction then I
can tell you what forces acting on you
can I say that any because that's
important I'm sipping a pigment example
if you can tell me how fast you're going
I can tell you what force is acting on
you how you're being accelerated ok when
can we think it can we think of examples
like this I gave you the rubber band for
this right which was depending on where
you are a force is acting on you in a
certain way can anyone think of a force
that acts on you in different ways
depending on how fast you're going your
resistance air resistance now admittedly
this is sort of thinking of this off the
top of your head is a bit physics biased
but it's ok now we can see all of it
together how does air resistance work
right well the first or something
travels through the air right the more
air is pushing back on it resisting it
right or you could say accelerating it
in the certain direction namely opposite
to where it's going ok and obviously if
you're standing still you're not
experiencing any resistance right it's
not pushing you in any particular
direction there's no acceleration acting
on whatever object you've got ok so this
is just one example um all I mean is
that we can understand things like this
query simple harmonic motion if we use
this equation
okay so let me give an example and this
is where i'm going to pick out support
motion okay you can recognize this as
simple honeymoon admission can't you
okay it fits this equation here right so
it's very simple the center of motion is
the origin right because it isn't this
kind of equation here and you can read
off that n is 2 and is too what does
that mean do you remember what n
signified in our original equation
living it it was it was it was period
wasn't it right remember that because
whether these equations can come from
they came from these kinds of examples
that's where m was do you remember and
so when you differentiate successive
times that's how the end comes out the
front because of chain rule right okay
so from this from this equation you can
already see not knowing anything else
the center of motion is the origin and
you can tell me something in that period
namely well if N equals 2 what it's the
period how do we do period remember it's
to pile on end isn't it to PI on em so
the period of motion is pi seconds okay
so this is really cool when you know
these kinds of things right the reason
we're developing these is so that of
this you can read things off really
quickly okay you can know things about
it even without doing any
differentiation attack those week
whether all right now how am I going to
use this result right watch I've got
acceleration in terms of displacement
right well if I have acceleration then I
can have velocity
okay this makes sense for two reasons
number one acceleration comes from
velocity right there that makes sense we
used to think about in terms of time but
that's not the only way you can think
about it in terms of think of it in
terms of displacement but also make
sense here because look see I have this
in terms of X right so I want to
integrate with respect to X that's what
you did over here right but I can do it
directly right because this is the on DX
right so I can integrate everything with
respect to X what's going to happen what
am I going to get on the left on the
right hand side when you integrate this
guy you'll just get happy squared right
that makes sense what happens over here
minus 2x squared and then you've got a
constant don't you okay I mean we've got
a constant for both me but we just sort
of London together okay now i want
velocity here that will get me back to
this kind of situation right so for
instance if i multiply both sides by two
you're going to get this for this reason
by the way you'll see some textbooks
will often introduce this as half see so
you can just just end up with a single
scene here it doesn't matter it's still
just a constant okay now have a look at
this for a second we better this is a
bit tricky there's a problem here if I
want to know velocity like something
like this okay I don't know the LA city
yet what do i know i know b squared
which really is a way of saying um I
know what speed is see that that there
is positive right so that's what speed
is it doesn't care about which direction
you're going in okay but I don't
actually know velocity I know velocity
squared okay so how do you go from here
to here like and actually get the sign
any suggestions
you'll need some kind of condition won't
you right but that you need more than
that yeah why have we arrived at this
why don't we got this equation I suppose
you're getting out in couple reasons
number one we got it from here right but
number two what kind of mission is this
we already knew from the first line what
kind of motion this was it's simple
harmonic right so therefore you ought to
be expect me to go in both directions
depending on where you are right by the
problem with these equations is it
strips out the app where you are
registering your in its troops out left
or right or up down because this is
squared n is your squared right so
that's why all you know is the magnitude
just to speed okay so in order to get
out of this you need to know more
information about the question they
would have to tell you more than just
this and then you'll be able to
determine the sign just off that you
can't tell okay that's I mean you don't
know remember this could have been this
could inside or it could be cause its
initial phase could be anything right
and so therefore you don't know which
way you're going at which time you just
know how fast you're going okay but this
is an example of how it works you start
with your differential equation here
right and this is what you want to
substitute him okay we'll see that you
don't need to prove that you can just
use it all right